certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même la
france n'est pas le seul pays qui a eu
des colonies dans le monde mais c'est le
seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter en partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche de l'intérêt de
leur population
et
[Musique]
devenez
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi à
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 6 octobre 2020
svetlana tirano sky à l'opposante au
président biélorusse est à berlin elle
s'est entretenu avec la chancelière
angela merkel
la chef de file de l'opposition appelle
les pays européens à maintenir la
pression notamment par des sanctions sur
le président alexandre loukachenko
svetlana attiré 9 sky a après avoir
rencontré emmanuel macron la semaine
dernière s'exprimera ce mercredi devant
l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
au mali ce pourrait être un heureux
dénouement sophie petrona dernier otage
française dans le monde et soumaïla
cissé l'une des plus hautes
personnalités politiques maliennes
auraient été libérés en fin d'après midi
les deux otages auraient pu retrouver
leur liberté
après un échange avec une centaines de
jihadistes condamné ou présumés
[Musique]
marseille paris et placés en zone
d'alerté maximale face au co vide avec
des mesures restrictives entrée en
vigueur aujourd'hui dans la capitale
elle les deux plus grandes villes
françaises semblent vouloir s'affranchir
du conseil scientifique nationale et
entendent créer le leur du côté de la
cité phocéenne la deuxième adjointe à la
mairie samia ghali la sueur ça prend
forme entre souveraineté agroalimentaire
et défense de la biodiversité à
l'assemblée nationale a tranché la nuit
dernière
si certains disent l'avoir fait à
contrecoeur les députés ont voté la
disposition clé du projet de loi
permettant la réintroduction temporaire
des néonicotinoïdes pour sauver la
filière betterave et ce jusqu'en 2023
alexis poulain reviendra sur ce vote et
ses conséquences ce sera notre rubrique
l'édito
[Musique]
et on débute sa avec l'opposante au
président alexandre loukachenko zvetlana
tirano sky à qui est à berlin depuis
hier et il ya rencontré ses partisans
qui manifestaient dans la capitale
allemande
elle s'est entretenue cet après midi
avec en guélat merkel demain svetlana
tirano sky a sera à paris pour
s'exprimer devant les parlementaires
français on écoute l'opposante
biélorusse après cet entretien avec la
chancelière allemande de moi même et le
peuple biélorusse sommes très
reconnaissants envers l'allemagne envers
tous les partis allemands qui ont tant
soutenu le peuple biélorusse dans son
combat pour la liberté et pour une
nouvelle élection honnête et
transparente and you own and
transportation and i know allez vous
savez ce que l'on m'a offert un
merveilleux cadeau n'est hissait peas et
c'est un morceau authentique du mur de
berlin
et c'est un peu un symbole de liberté
freedom et je suis sûr que notre mur
notre propre mur au sein de notre pays
sera abattu très bientôt
merci beaucoup pour votre soutien
ensemble nous vaincrons
alors depuis fin septembre c'est un
tapis rouge diplomatique que déroule
paris et berlin à la candidate surprise
de la présidentielle le biélorusse âgé
de 37 ans d'où cette interrogation ce
soir à biélorussie l'europe à la
manoeuvre place à notre décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous accueillons
eugène berg ancien ambassadeur de france
auteur de la russie pour les nuls
bonsoir à vos côtés bon choix
à vos côtés frédéric sinclair
éditorialiste ancien conseiller
diplomatique de dominique de villepin à
bonsoir alors messieurs on le disait un
réception en grande pompe pour
l'opposante biélorusses dans un contexte
diplomatique particulier entre la russie
et l'europe on pense notamment à la
sphère navalni alors ce contexte
particulier svetlana tirano sky à 100
certaines comme un ressort finalement
aux jeunes bergues
écoutez elle a été elle a été une grande
surprise
d'abord parce que le cash and co ne
faisait pas confiance aux femmes
finalement il n'a pas vu son aura et
qu'elle pouvait lui être lui rassemblé
un son de voix on va pas parler du nom
de voix c'est controversé c'est pas
toujours très claires et finalement elle
et elle s'est comportée on dit que c'est
une novice elle s'est comportée avec une
habilité assez forte
une certaine maturité pour quelqu'un qui
n'avait jamais fait politique et qui
s'est abrité derrière son époux qui lui
incarcéré alors par exemple elle a
toujours dit que elle reste une femme
une mère et qu'elle est là pour suppléer
journal alors là j'ai écouté son
discours qui est très bref en anglais
elle est interprète d'engrais elle a dit
deux choses à mon sens qu'ils sont un
peu nouvelle les promeneurs la première
c'est qu'il faut exercer des sanctions
contre loukachenko
les auditeurs seront se souviendront
certainement qu'une quarantaine de
personnalités biélorusses ont déjà été
sanctionnés mais pas le président là la
demande et que des pressions soient
faites sur le président lui même et pour
montrer son sens de l'opportunité sont
disons la manière dont elle a déjà les
elle sait parler aux médias elle a reçu
un mur de berre
1 il a fait évidemment le parallèle
après le mur de berlin je suis sûr que
le mur et qui est dans mon pays va aussi
s'abattre et donc appel du pied de
l'europe mais elle n'a pas parlé de la
médiation
elle en parlera peut-être demain elle
attend une médiation
elles attendent à une médiation du
président emmanuel macron avec leurs sms
et e là aussi c'est pas tout à fait
clair notre président dit qui a l'aval
de vladimir poutine
est ce que c'est vraiment acté à qui est
ce qu'elle a demandé
il faudra le voir dans les minutes ou
dans les heures qui vont venir est ce
qu'elle demande aux gays une médiation
également de angela merkel qui est quand
même président l'union européenne
est ce que c'est une médiation française
une médiation franco-allemande
européenne là aussi faudra éclaircir
parce que certainement l'ensemble des 27
seront pas à 100% sur une ligne dure une
ligne 10 ans de confrontation mais
plutôt une ligne de dots de continuer le
dialogue et de pousser à la médiation et
de pousser finalement une sortie aussi
j'allais dire aussi calme si on peut
parler de calme parce que comme des
violences les manifestations des
arrestations
voilà un petit peu le sens de ce message
qui a été très bref en quelque sorte
frédéric saint clair on connaît aussi de
tensions autour du projet de gazoduc
nord stream ii est ce que ce dossier
s'imbriquent également avec celui de la
biélorussie dans les intérêts dans les
intérêts européens
alors oui vous parlez d'intéresser c'est
le sait le mot on est dans un dans un
rapport de puissance tout dans les tous
dans les relations internationales
finalement ce ses relations
internationales
elle simplifie parfois un petit peu là
la mécanique politique parce que le la
recherche d'intérêts
politique pour le peuple ou économiques
pour le pour le peuple est clairement
assumé bien souvent dans la politique
nationale on nous fait entrer diverses
notions idéologique pour la politique
internationale c'est souvent plus clair
dans le cas qui nous occupe là la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est quels
sont les intérêts des biélorusses
quels sont les intérêts des français et
des allemands et ensuite quel est
l'intérêt de vladimir poutine
si tous les intérêts comme j'aime berg
vient le préciser si tous les intérêts
convergent à la fois à l'ouest de la
biélorussie et à l'est
il est possible il est possible qu'on
puisse trouver un
un compromis une voie de sortie qui va
contraindre politiquement fortement le
président loukachenko
si ce n'est pas le cas et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas pour
des raisons assez simple c'est que là la
biélorussie est une zone tampon entre
l'actuelle union européenne et la russie
et bertrand badie a beau avoir écrit la
fin des territoires je crois que on
n'assiste pas encore la fin des
territoires et que ces territoires ont
une importance et qu'aujourd'hui pour la
russie
gardez la biélorussie dans son giron ça
reste un enjeu majeur alors vous avez
mentionné north stream effectivement il
ya des enjeux énergétiques mais
simplement des enjeux aussi économique à
vous rappeler que en 2010 une union
douanière a été mise en place entre la
biélorussie la russie et le kazakhstan
si ma mémoire est bonne
donc il ya des enjeux économiques une
union douanière et quand même un projet
économique fort donc où se trouve
finalement la ligne de partage entre les
intérêts de vladimir poutine et ceux de
l'union européenne représentée par le
franco allemand alors justement le jeune
belge qu'est l'intérêt partage paris et
berlin en étant à la manoeuvre dans le
dossier biélorusse c'est quoi des
intérêts financiers des intérêts d'
influence de territoire expliqué
nouveaux gènes
non je pense que c'est ni l'un ni
l'autre c'est simplement la france et
l'allemagne
j'irai pas que s'arrogent le droit de
parler au nom des européens au nom de la
famille européenne
je pense que ils veulent jouer un rôle
parce que c'est comme de puissance bon
l'allemagne est pas loin des frontières
vous savez la famille européenne est
quand même gérer un peu divisé et il
faut apaiser les craintes
bon je vais pas faire une typologie de
toutes les positions l'intérieur il est
évident que les pays baltes la pologne
sont très offensives je vais pas refaire
l'histoire
une partie des territoires biélorusses
ont été dans le grand duché ponot
lituanien une partie du territoire de la
pologne est passée la biélorussie après
et c'est pas pour rien que en 89 quand
il y avait un front national en
biélorussie c'est le sache ou 10 le
mouvement lituanien d'indépendance donc
tout ça n'est pas mort évidemment le
disons que pour un électeur français
moyen c'est loin c'est un peu compliqué
mais cette histoire est là c'est bien la
pologne et la lituanie qui accueille
déjà depuis longtemps les opposants
donne des bourses aux étudiants
donc là il ya une manifestation un
combat géopolitique qui dure depuis des
décennies des siècles qui continue et
voilà je ne dirais pas qu'ils mettent
systématiquement l'huile sur le feu mais
ils le font alors la france et
l'allemagne sont bon j'irai pas qu'ils
veulent apaiser mais réduire un peu les
tensions bribes et un petit peu la pole
la lituanie parce qu'ils ont besoin
d'elle ils peuvent pas ils peuvent pas
s'opposer on a besoin finalement puisque
l'europe ne marche que par les compromis
permanent donc on doit un petit peu les
dans leur sens pour les apaiser pour les
[ __ ] en quelque sorte parce que là
aussi le président macron tu vas dessus
faut lui rendre hommage
il est allé il a effectivement
rencontrer l'opposante souhaitait un
groupe pas facile à prononcer
sinofsky il a il a dit que je suis
toujours
maintenir une architecture de paix et de
sécurité avec la russie donc quelle que
soit l'évolution de la biélorussie il
faut espérer qu'il y aura pas
d'intervention extérieure qu'on va pas
tirer sur les foules
certes la violence pour l'instant les
contenus où il ya comme la guerre au
karabakh
c'est un palier mais il ya une autre
violence donc le monde est loin d'être
calme
on le voit pas donc et je crois que la
france et l'allemagne jouent ce rôle
pour préserver cette architecture de
paix de sécurité pour maintenir le
dialogue car s'il ya pas dialogue et la
confrontation et je crois qu'on a
suffisamment à faire dans d'autres
endroits de la planète pour en ajouter
une voie là le grand message alors qu'il
faut comprendre vécu alors évolutive ans
on va y revenir aux relations franco
russes aujourd'hui mais avant frédéric
sinclair je vous pose la la mais la même
question qu'est ce que l'on voit à
l'oeuvre du côté de paris et berlin est
ce que c'est la défaite la défense
d'intérêts financiers
ou alors d'intérêt d'un finances de
territoire il y a globalement une
défense d'un modèle politique on
pourrait presque dire idéologique un
rapport à la la façon à la puissance qui
est prônée par l'ensemble de l'occident
europe etats unis compris qui est le
modèle de la démocratie libérale et face
à cela on a une division au sein même de
l'europe c'est-à-dire ce modèle de la
démocratie libérale est contesté au sein
même de l'europe et aux frontières de
l'europe
est ce qu'on est en train de voir
émerger c'est un autre modèle politique
qui n'est pas libérale qui n'est pas
complètement illibérale non plus parce
qu'on a beau dire ce qu'on veut mais la
hongrie n'est pas non plus un exemple du
libéralisme ans n'est pas en iran ou en
chine et donc il ya un autre modèle
politique à notre projet politique
démocratique qui est en train d'émerger
emmanuel macron et angela merkel sont
opposés à ce modèle là ensuite se
greffent là-dessus ce que clément bonne
donc été le conseiller
deux des manuels macro qui est devenu
aujourd'hui secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes a nommé le besoin
pour la france 2 pour hull pour l'homme
l'union européenne de parler le langage
de la puissance donc début septembre
dans une interview sur lci
il parle de souveraineté européenne il
réaffirme la volonté macro nien d'une
souveraineté européenne est donc là on
voit émerger à travers son discours la
volonté de puissance de du couple
franco-allemand qui parle au nom de
l'ensemble de l'europe alors qu' il n'y
a pas d'unité en réalité et qui cherche
à diriger l'europe vers une forme de
souveraineté
il parle dans cette interview de
souveraineté militaire quand il parle
d'une armée il réactive le vieux serpent
de mer de l'armée européenne
il parle de souveraineté européenne de
frontières européennes et donc on voit
bien qu'on a un rapport de puissance est
logique de puissance qui est
complètement différente
l'enjeu en biélorussie est où eh bien il
est de ramener la biélorussie vers
l'union européenne
on voit bien que le modèle qui est porté
par des rénos callas c'est un modèle de
démocratie libérale façon europe de
l'ouest en tout cas c'est ce que
emmanuel macron anticiper c'est pour ça
qu'il prend fait et cause pour elle sans
chercher à apaiser le dialogue est donc
finalement à à trouver une voie médiane
entre leucate cinquetti ranocchia
il prend fait et cause pour thierno ce
qu'elle est c'est-à-dire qu'il dit on va
ramener la biélorussie vers nous lorsque
vladimir poutine dit à leucate shinko
qui lui assurera une sécurité militaire
de manière à ce que la paix et la
protection du peuple biélorusse soit
assurée je pense qu'il l'a dante est lui
aussi qu'il est possible de développer
un modèle politique qui ne soit pas
celui de l'europe de l'ouest
donc en fait c'est ça à mon avis dans la
relation de puissance qui se joue qui
est la clé est-ce que la biélorussie est
amené à intégrer l'union européenne ou
pas alors de personnes clés emmanuel
macron vladimir poutine
eugène baird le chef de l'état français
avait envisagé un cet été de se rendre
en russie pour
rencontrer vladimir poutine le revoir
une visite reporté aujourd'hui
finalement peu évoqué un sur le plan
diplomatique ou est-ce qu'on en est à
propos du réchauffement des relations
entre paris et moscou
est-ce que je peux rebondir ce qu'a dit
le préfet c'est donc sur le nom parce
que bon jeu en est on est là bas on
n'est pas là pour polémiquer
à mon sens bon c'est peut-être sous
jacent mais je pense pas qu emmanuel
macron veut attirer la biélorussie dans
l'union européenne puisque déjà
souvenez vous en avril 2008 la géorgie
et l'ukraine c'est la france et
l'allemagne qui s'était opposée donc si
on se pose à la géorgie à l'ukraine on
va s'opposer encore plus parce que la
biélorussie finale offre il faut le voir
c'est une partie de la rue si je dirais
pas que c'est un pays quasiment
artificiel c'est un pays dont la langue
est très proche qui n'a jamais fait pas
vraiment été indépendant l'identité est
encore plus restreinte que l'ukraine
non le but je crois que le président m'a
kron a dit je suis pour nouvelles
élections parce que je considère que
celle ci était quand même trop trop
entaché d'erreurs et c'est au peuple
biélorusse de décider donc des élections
une nouvelle constitution et nouveau
pouvoir
mais je ne pense pas qu'il ait eu la
naïveté où les dix ont l'outrecuidance
de dire on va la tirer à nous parce que
s'il dit ça alors là c'est une très
grave erreur
joe politique la russie ne peut pas
laisser la biélorussie comme alors à soi
disant laissé l'ukraine
non là là il faut être très clair elle
avale et l'élargissement de l'otan et
les avaler beaucoup de choses là c'est
un point de non retour et même beaucoup
d'américains luddisme je crois que là il
faut que ce soit clair alors qu'il
aurait dit on à l'agencé russe voilà il
nous reste quelques secondes messieurs
peut-être pour conclure l'un après
l'autre
un mot sur les relations franco russes
aujourd'hui en un mot le jeune berg et
puis vous conclurez frédéric saint clair
alors bon le mot malheureusement
effectivement emmanuel macron devait
être à moscou le 9 mai pour le 75e
anniversaire de la victoire
il avait été critiqué pourquoi les à
moscou
il voulait y aller le la pandémie
l'empêcher avant évidemment la sphère
navalni il était prêt à moscou
vous savez il faut rien exclure si
effectivement les temps sur une baisse
ce qu'il faut gérer pas que faut prier
dieu parce qu'ils sont très croyants nos
amis russes
donc faut peut-être prier dieu et par
lénine pour que ça s'apaise c'est peu
probable mais c'est pas tout à fait
exclue vous savez la vie internationale
est pleine d'imprévus et on verra et là
effectivement si ça s'apaise et bien
emmanuel macron pourrait y aller
est-ce qui va parler au nom de leurs
apps ou pas bon s'il ya peu de chance
mais c'est pas totalement exclu et ça
serait finalement un scénario où il y
aura une rencontre entre les deux
présidents l'un par leur est évidemment
un peu au nom de l'europe
il faudrait qu'ils discutent qu'il avait
pas seul et donc dans les trois mois où
ou avant c'est un scénario qu'il faut
pas exclure
c'est à dario évidemment optimiste alors
je ne dirai pas que je le souhaite mais
j'espère encore qu'il n'est pas
totalement éliminés dans les mois à
venir et je crois qu'il faut y fonder
là-dessus autrement on doit honorer l on
doit conclure malheureusement on va
laisser le mot de la fin pour frédéric
que sinclair en quelques secondes s'il
vous plaît
en quelques secondes je maintiens je
maintiens mon analyse je pense que si
emmanuel macron on n'envisage pas une
intégration stricto sensu de de la
biélorussie en réalité ils la
considèrent potentiellement comme un
pivot géostratégique c'est à dire comme
le brésil qui les appeler certains
fument forme de satellites de l'union
européenne il cherche à étendre la la la
la puissance de l'union européenne sa
souveraineté et son influence il
raisonne en termes d'ampyra emmanuel
macron est donc globalement lempire
voisins c'est l' empire russe et donc de
ce fait là il faut qu'il y ait un
dialogue avec la russie mais ce dialogue
là ne se veut pas naïfs pour emmanuel
macron stains un rapport de puissance il
imagine qu'il va pouvoir rééquilibrer le
rapport de puissance entre l'union
européenne et la russie ce qui à mon
avis est une faute pour deux raisons la
première c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
souveraineté européenne et qu'il n'y en
aura pas puisque c'est une collection
pays et la deuxième c'est parce que leur
la conception de la puissance européenne
est une puissance géoéconomique
uniquement n'est pas capable de faire
autre chose que de
de placer des sanctions économiques
alors que la conception de la puissance
russe et complète il ya une dimension
économique mais aussi une dimension
militaire affirmé on l'a vu en ukraine
vous pourrez le voir ailleurs un grand
merci à tous les deux merci eugène
berger rappelle que vous êtes ancien
ambassadeur de france essayiste merci à
vous frédéric sinclair éditorialiste
ancien conseiller politique de dominique
de villepin au mali maintenant la cedeao
aux lève finalement an ses sanctions à
l'encontre du pays une décision pour
soutenir la transition vers un retour
des civils au pouvoir
le pays était sous embargo commercial et
financier depuis le coup d'état du 18
août qui a renversé l'ancien président y
bk mais face à la nomination d'un
gouvernement de transition hier
l'organisation d'afrique de l'ouest a
salué je cite à des avancées notables
vers la normalisation constitutionnel
pour soutenir ce processus les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement décide de la
levée des sanctions sur le mali il
appelle tous les partenaires bilatéraux
et multilatéraux à soutenir le mali les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement demande
aux nouvelles autorités de la transition
de mettre en oeuvre rapidement les
autres décisions du sommet en
particulier la libération de tous les
officiels militaires et civils arrêtés
depuis le 18 août 2020 et la dissolution
du comité national pour le salut du
peuple n'est toujours au mali sophie
petro nar ne serait plus captivé elle
aurait été libérée dans l'après-midi
avec soumaïla cissé c'est l'une des plus
hautes personnalités politiques
maliennes retour sur près de quatre ans
de captivité avec sa mère sa bille et
pierre émile jan masaryk
sophie petrona 75 ans a été enlevée le
24 décembre 2016 à gao au nord du mali à
l'époque cet humanitaire française est
installée dans le pays depuis plusieurs
années elle dirige une organisation des
dalles enfance en 2018
elle en appelle au président emmanuel
macron l'année suivante lors d'un
hommage à deux soldats français tués au
burkina faso le président français
évoque sophie petrona affirmant que la
france n'abandonne jamais ses enfants
c'est une lueur d'espoir pour la famille
petrona dernière otage française dans le
monde sofi petrona ne devrait pas sortir
seul
soumaïla cissé et que ce chef de
l'opposition parlementaire est candidat
à trois reprises à l'élection
présidentielle malienne kidnappé le 25
mars dernier doit lui aussi bénéficié de
cet échange plus d'une centaines de
jihadistes condamné ou présumés ont été
libérés au mali de week-end dernier
après des tractations entre la jante
malienne et le groupe de soutien à
l'islam et aux musulmans liés à al qaïda
par le passé des échanges de prisonniers
avaient déjà eu lieu mais jamais autant
de détenus n'avaient été relâchés des
geôles malienne
au total sophie petronas aura reste et
1381 jours en détention après avoir
consacré sa vie aux orphelins du sahel
et pour en parler nous sommes avec le
neveu de sophie petrona lionel
granouillac bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
quelles sont les dernières nouvelles
concernant votre tante que vous pouvez
nous le partage et on sait que son fils
à votre cousin est arrivé à bamako
d'écouté dans la tente toujours de la
confirmation officielle des autorités
françaises mais on sait de par des
recoupements d'informations et pas mal
de dépêches qui ont dit qu'ils ont été
diffusés assez crédible sur le net
je pense pouvoir dire ce soir qu'elle
est libre qu'elle est en cours
d'acheminement entre gao et et bamako
ce sont les infos les dernières infos
que d'autres dont on dispose et donc
effectivement c'est un soulagement pour
elle après presque quatre ans de
captivité
donc j'attends bien sûr le visuel
j'attends d'eux je vois que vous diffusé
son portrait avec sébastien mon cousin
j'attends justement cette photo cette
image parce que il s'est battu pendant
quatre ans pour pour la sortir et il
mérite vraiment aujourd'hui 2 le 7 cette
délivrance et j'attends quand même ce
visuel pour être complètement libérés
mais voilà on est extrêmement confiant
la famille et tous nos proches qui me
soutiennent vous nous le dites ce soir 1
sophie petrona serait donc libre après
quatre ans de captivité est ce que vous
avez eu des nouvelles ces derniers jours
des autorités du ministère des affaires
étrangères par exemple est ce que vous
étiez en lien ces derniers temps avec
les autorités pour voir un dossier qui
bouge pas du tout on n'a pas eu de
contacts très récent mise à part pour
entre guillemets une carte
d'anniversaire le 7 juillet pour ses 75
ans ou la cellule de crise à bien a eu
des mots plein de bienveillance et
empathie et bon je peux vous dire que
nous sommes en contact évidemment
actuellement que pour l'instant les
autorités françaises ne veulent pas
confirmer tant que je pense ils n'auront
pas eu la certitude qu'elles soient dans
en sécurité et que du personnel de chez
eux le et pu rendre compte
votre combat le combat de votre famille
depuis quatre ans at il enfin porter ses
fruits comment vous vous êtes mobilisés
pendant toutes ces années et tous ces
mois alors c'est difficile de
synthétiser quatre ans de lutte
mais bon on a commencé par créer dès la
revendication de son enlèvement a
commencé par créer un comité de soutien
qui s'appelle libérons tir et sophie
point fr et ensuite
voilà on a pris contact et surtout
sébastien fait de nombreux voyages sur
site
que ce soit au mali au niger plaque
tournante souvent des négociations ou à
nouakchott pour prendre contact pour se
rapprocher au plus près d'elle de
jusqu'en décembre 2018 à obtenir et bien
d un intermédiaire et un contact fiable
qui aurait pu permettre sa libération un
processus de négociation que l'état
français n'a pas volu appliqué et donc
le la position du président macron était
a toujours été de ne pas vouloir
négocier
donc on s'est pas découragée on a avec
mon frère arnaud montre que jean-pierre
aussi on a continué et est soutenu
sébastien aussi dans ses actions
même si ça a été difficile parce que ça
a été beaucoup de sacrifices et je pense
notamment ma cousine
séverine et à ses trois enfants
qui pendant de longues semaines à
endurer aussi le spectre de de ses
voyages avec des inquiétudes de savoir
s'il y allait revenir
lionel gabriac malheureusement le temps
qui nous est imparti va bientôt se
terminer voilà en tout cas ce soir vous
nous le dit sophie petrona est en route
apparemment à vers la liberté on attend
bien entendu la confirmation des
autorités en tout cas un grand merci
pour votre témoignage lionel granouillac
je rappelle que vous êtes le neveu de
sophie petronas est resté avec nous sur
rt france dans quelques instants nous
parlerons des universités françaises où
le virus circule activement la jauge
d'accueil des étudiants est abaissé de
50 % dans les villes en zone d' alerte
maximale
puis nous évoquerons le retour des
néonicotinoïdes dans les champs de
betteraves sucrières avec alexis poulain
ce sera notre rubrique l'édito a tout de
suite sur rt france
[Musique]
une trump est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française et on poursuit avec cette
déclaration de l'organisation pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques l'eau
eyath et valide la thèse qu'une
substance du type novice choc a été
identifié dans l'organisme de l'opposant
russe alexeï navalni il avait été prise
en charge à berlin dans un état grave à
la suite d'un empoisonnement présumés
lowy assez indique que les échantillons
de sang et d'uriné de navalni contenait
un inhibiteur de la colline estérase
similaire de substances chimiques de
type nos vies chuck interdite par
l'organisation en 2019
les précisions de peter aux divers
correspondants de rta berne à loyat
c'est l'organisation pour l'interdiction
des armes chimiques envoyé un document
détaillé à berlin mais il semblerait
qu'il ne soit pas encore d'après les
remarques de dimitri peskov porte-parole
du kremlin
parvenu jusqu'à moscou pour l'allemagne
il devra y avoir des conséquences suite
aux révélations de loyat c'est à berlin
alors on a appelé à moscou ont des
explications sur ce qui est arrivé
alexeï navalni stefan seifert
porte-parole du gouvernement allemand a
déclaré qu'il ne pouvait pas y avoir
d'utilisation d'une arme chimique sans
graves conséquences
ce lundi l'eau y as et a déclaré qu'elle
allait partager des informations sur
l'emploi zone mende alexeï navalni avec
moscou dont des éléments prouvant qu
alexeï navalni a été empoisonné par un
agents neurotoxiques de la famille d'une
vie jack ac a également déclaré qu'elle
serait prête à envoyer une équipe en
russie pour contribuer à l'anc est le
premier ministre russe sergueï lavrov a
déclaré que la russie était frustré par
la manière d'agir de l'allemagne en
matière de partage des informations au
secours envoyé trois requêtes à berlin
pour des informations sur le cac navalni
qui ont été ignorées berlin on étudie en
ce moment une quatrième
monsieur lavrov
certains des partenaires européens de la
russie ont déjà pris position sur la
sphère navalni avant même que tout soit
éclairci nous savons pour le moment que
selon loïc assez alexeï navalni a été
empoisonné par un agents neurotoxiques
de la famille du new york
ils ont transmis cette information à
berlin le gouvernement allemand pense
qu'il ya des questions auxquelles moscou
doit répondre et il pourrait y avoir des
répercussions sérieuses à l'utilisation
d'une alchimie la situation sanitaire en
france à présent face à l'évolution de
l'épidémie les universités notamment à
paris bordeaux ou marseille
un prenne de nouvelles mesures le
gouvernement a demandé par circulaire
aux chefs d'établissements situés en
zone d' alerte renforcée et en zone d'
alerte maximale d'instaurer une jauge
pour tous les espaces où les élèves
pouvaient être regroupés elle est
classée amphithéâtre les espaces de
restauration ou encore les bibliothèques
universitaires devront être à 50% au
plus de leur capacité nominale et ce dès
ce mardi à paris assas le fonctionnement
de moitié dans fille est déjà en place
les étudiants l'ont expliqué au micro de
rtl france en fait c'est sur la base de
listes alphabétiques donc 2 à m
une semaine et la deuxième semaine c'est
de mazda5 les semaines ça change
alors pour l'instant on est prévenu
uniquement sur deux semaines on a pas
encore d'informations pour le reste du
mois ni pour les mois suivants donc ça
peut changer mais pour l'instant ça
fonctionne comme ça je pense que le
système là d' ordre alphabétique
on aurait pu faire mieux alors voilà
j'ai encore une fois j'ai pas forcément
d'idées en tête mais mais on voit que la
fac avec un petit peu surprise et elle
aurait pu se préparer davantage à
quelque chose qui était prévisible parce
que c'est tous les ans fait tous les ans
on a cette population dans les amphis à
la rentrée ça se voit qu'ils avaient
beaucoup de monde c'est normal on est en
jeu c'est la rentrée tout le monde dit
en cours à la rentrée après généralement
ça arrange mais il ya toujours beaucoup
de monde à la rentrée c'est vrai que vu
la situation s'est un peu plus choquant
de voir autant de monde à la fac pour
ceux qui sont chez eux ils auront les
podcasts qui sont filmés le jour même et
qui sont sur le site de la fac
dans la journée ou le lendemain ils ont
tous les tous les podcasts et les vidéos
de cours normalement à leur disposition
sur le site et pour en parler nous
sommes avec eux jacques smith
porte-parole de l'uni zack smith merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors
très concrètement on a entendu un
étudiant d'assas dire que finalement
c'était divisé par ordre alphabétique 1
avec ces nouvelles mesures dans les
autres facultés comment est ce que les
étudiants se répartissent acquis et est
réservé le présentiel
alors déjà cette affaire montre
plusieurs choses et le montre
premièrement une préparation complète et
totale du ministère sur sur cette crise
ça fait six mois que l'école unis
demandent à une préparation de cette
rente et qui ce qui qui que conserver
stratégique puisque sa nasse ça fait six
mois cela faisait six mois que les clés
que les étudiants et que les que les
cinq étaient fermés donc ça montre
premièrement une impréparation totale du
ministère et puis deuxièmement et puis
l'étudiante le disait très bien les
étudiants sont la communauté étudiante
dans son ensemble est complètement dans
le flou et les étudiants apprennent le
dimanche soir des mesures qui vont qui
se rendent à appliquer le lendemain donc
donc les étudiants sont dans le flou est
ce là le mystère en est clairement
fautif en tout cas est ce que c'est une
bonne méthode un bon cap pour lutter
contre l'épidémie selon vous alors nous
on pense clairement que de toutes les
façons heureusement que les
établissements de l'enseignement
supérieur n'ont pas attendu les annonces
et notamment cette dernière annonce de
50% pour pouvoir gérer la crise
le ministère a complètement lâché les
états une censure cette crise sanitaire
et ce depuis longtemps les ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'aujourd'hui on en parle
et l'étudiant que vous avez interrogé en
parlait très bien c'est que les groupes
de promos sont distingués en plusieurs
parties notamment deux parties avec un
groupe à et un groupe b et où vous avez
le premier groupe en distance yens
pendant que l'autre et en présentiel et
cela les établissements l'ont déjà mis
en place depuis depuis la rentrée et
donc le ministère est arrivé fort tard
très tard et cela prouve un attentisme
forcené de la part de ces ministères qui
devrait pour pour nous être cette année
le gardien
en tout cas effectivement comme vous
parle est une institution qui donne le
cap pour l'établissement et pour la
korité étudiante dans son ensemble et
pour tous les acteurs qui est qui
s'occupe de l'enseignement supérieur
français sur trois priorités qui sont
pour nous maximale c'est premièrement de
préserver la formation de qualité la
formation d'excellence de notre de nos
universités
on a pu voir l'année dernière décade
dans certains universités ou des
matières entière et des données à des
promotions et des années et ait été
donné de neutralisation de semestre
était donc ça c'est un problème
premièrement pour effectivement la
qualité et l'excellence de nos
formations et de nos diplômes et l'image
de nos universités deuxièmement
accompagné voilà les étudiants dans dans
la crise sociale et économique qui
arrivent il faut bien savoir que la
précarité étudiante augmente avec avec
cette crise sanitaire et la communauté
étudiante est touché et donc il faut
faire attention à cela et puis
troisièmement essayer d'accompagner
aussi les étudiants dans leur insertion
professionnelle et faire en sorte que
que c'est un assassin professionnel
puisse encore exister on parlait donc du
premier axe qui étaient là la formation
de qualité qui est en fait en lien avec
la continuité pédagogique qui doit
encore avoir lieu cette année malgré la
crise met mais aussi le troisième axe
est clairement l'insertion
professionnelle des tout nouveaux
diplômés qui rendent sur un marché du
travail qui est qui est largement douter
est ce que vous savez s'il ya eu des
budgets débloqués si vous avez des
moyens débloqués justement pour vous
aider face à tête à cette crise
sanitaire à ces nouvelles mesures à ce
que les universités au fond peuvent
suivre
je vous donnerai deux exemples précis et
concret là dessus premièrement oui il ya
eu des choses fait et heureusement
heureusement de la part du ministère il
ya eu des choses celle de puits et
depuis le début de cette crise il ya eu
premièrement par exemple le repas à 1
euro pour les boursiers
mais nous on pense que c'est bien
évidemment ça va dans le bon sens mais
que ça ne touche pas l'ensemble de la
communauté étudiante qui dans l'ensemble
est touché par cette prise
ça ne touche pas les étudiants non
boursiers issus des classes moyennes qui
sont aussi eux très durement touchée par
cette crise et puis ça ne touche pas les
étudiants qui n'ont pas tout simplement
de cafétéria ou de restaurer restaurant
universitaire puisque il serait dans des
sites délocalisés ou autre
donc tout le monde n'a pas forcément
l'opportunité de pouvoir manger appris à
prix étudiant le midi et puis
deuxièmement il ya aussi pour
l'insertion professionnelle typiquement
des choses qui ont été faites mais des
choses aussi qui ont été refusés de la
part du ministère nous on a proposé par
exemple l'année dernière de faire de
faire en sorte que les entreprises à
l'embauché d'un tout nouveau diplômé et
d'un jeune de moins de 30 ans puisse
être exonérés des charges patronales et
7 et 7 cette mesure n'a premièrement pas
été pas été soutenu par par le ministère
et deuxièmement été largement refusé et
a refusé par la majorité présidentielle
donc nous on demande juste effectivement
qu'il y ait des mesures concrètes forte
efficace sur ces trois points qui pour
nous sont les priorités et les priorités
pour l'ensemble des étudiants une fois
pour conclure quels sont les échanges
que vous pouvez avoir avec vous vos
enseignants comment est-ce que ça se
passe quel est leur ressenti est ce
qu'ils craignent justement pour leurs
conditions de travail et peut-être pour
une baisse de l'enseignement à court
moyen terme
c'est vrai que les enseignants ils sont
comme comme on disait un pur comme tous
les hommes tous les acteurs dans cette
crise sont touchés par cette crise et
ils se disent est ce qu'on va pouvoir
eux de leur côté on va pouvoir continuer
à former nos étudiants à faire ensemble
que cette formation soit toujours de
qualité et et pour faire en sorte
surtout que les étudiants puissent à la
fin de l'année se dire ben voilà on a eu
quand même une année d'études
supérieures et que des enseignants
puissent se dire voilà on a on a pu
transmettre le savoir c'est quand même
l'objectif principal de ces professeurs
les propres et safari sont tout
simplement aussi voilà ils se disent
comme les étudiants cette année va être
compliqué mais il faut que tout le monde
y met du sien pour pour que pour que les
choses se passent bien et dans le
bonheur merci beaucoup jack smith
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes porte-parole de
l'uni betteraves contre abeilles les
députés ont choisi ils ont voté cette
nuit la disposition clé du projet de loi
et qui permet la réintroduction
temporaire des néonicotinoïdes pour
sauver la filière betterave
ces insecticides néfaste pour les av
interdit en 2018 pierre jan mazari avec
mathilde romagnan projet de loi
controversé
le texte sur les néonicotinoïdes a été
votée cette nuit à l'assemblée nationale
pour lutter contre la prolifération de
la jaunisse sur les betteraves le
gouvernement réintroduit temporairement
ces insecticides tueur d'abeilles
interdit en 2018
une décision qui provoque l'ire des
écologistes et de certains membres de la
majorité
il accuse le gouvernement de
rétropédaler sur le dossier sensible de
la transition écologique
j'appelle les députés à ne pas voter
cette loi prolonge l usage des
néonicotinoïdes pour la filière de la
betterave
alors que leur interdiction a été votée
en 2016 ce n'est pas une solution ce
n'est pas constructive ce n'est pas
prospectifs le secteur de la betterave
est depuis longtemps en difficulté pour
des raisons structurelles
un appel qui n'a visiblement pas été
entendu car selon matignon cette
dérogation permettra de préserver les
emplois de 46 mille personnes dont 25
mille agriculteurs
c'est une question de souveraineté
nombre de planteurs en ce moment-même
évite à replanter des betteraves
si les sucreries ferme c'est toute la
filière de la betterave qui peut
disparaître en une ou deux saisons
de nouvelles mesures ont été introduites
en commission la création d'un conseil
de surveillance et l'interdiction sur
des parcelles où ont été utilisées des
néonicotinoïdes d'implanter les cultures
attirant les abeilles afin de ne pas les
exposer et pour en parler nous sommes
avec alexis poule à c'est notre rubrique
l'édito
[Musique]
alexis poulain bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors pourquoi cet
insecticide est de retour et suscite
tant de débats oui alors les
néonicotinoïdes ces insecticides donc
pesticides tueurs d'abeilles comme ils
sont appelés inventé dans les années 80
par les géants de la chimie basf
bailleurs et qui sont encore largement
utilisés dans le monde 1 entre un quart
et un tiers des pesticides sont issus de
ces molécules dangereuses pour la
biodiversité dangereuse pour le vivant
ils reviennent sur le débat parce qu'ils
avaient été interdits en 2016 en 2018
il devait disparaître cette année mais
voilà la filière betterave s'est plaint
elle n'a pas trouvé de substitut à ces
molécules pour lutter contre des
pucerons qui donne la jaunisse de la
betterave et qui pourrait mettre en
péril 30 à 50% de la production de
betteraves sucrières en france
alors pour le gouvernement c'est
effectivement des emplois de cette
filière de l'agriculture 46 mille
emplois 25000 emplois dans l'agriculture
mais aussi dans la modification et le
business agroalimentaire donc il faut
choisir l'économie plutôt que l'écologie
et on décide d'abroger de dates de
finalement reculer pour mieux sauter la
filière betterave pourra donc continuer
d'utiliser ces molécules des
néonicotinoïdes jusqu'en 2023 en
demandant à chaque année
une autorisation pour avoir le droit
d'utiliser sa et encore une fois c'est
grâce à l'union européenne que les néo
nicotine et ne reviennent en france
parce que les lois de non concurrence ne
permettent pas au gouvernement d'
indemniser à 100 % les agriculteurs qui
ne pourraient pas cultiver leur
betteraves et puis en europe
nos voisins européens continuent de les
utiliser les lois européennes en matière
de volée culte chimiques sont moins
disantes au niveau écologique et donc il
n'y a aucune raison que les agriculteurs
français ne puissent pas eux aussi
pollué les sols et les eaux comme leurs
voisins et produire de la betterave
sucrière donc le choix était simple re
de revenir sur les règles qui avaient
été édictées en 2018 et réintroduire ces
nos petits no id pour la filière
betterave soi-disant alors on peut le
souligner alexis un insecticide rejetée
par beaucoup d'élus et qui divise même
la majorité oui alors malgré le vote à
majoritaire 313 pourrait seulement 218
contre au sein de la majorité que ce
soit elle errait modem ou les nouveaux
groupes qui se sont créé de nombreux
députés à sensibilité écologique ont
jugé cette reculade rétrograde
dangereuse même pour la santé et ont
même qualifié ce choix d'être une boîte
de pandore parce que le gouvernement n'a
pas noté dans la loi que ce retour des
néonicotinoïdes était seulement pour la
filière betterave parce que cela aurait
risqué et bien de faire que c'est toi
soit caduc retoquée par le conseil
constitutionnel donc n'importe quelle
filière de production pourrait et bien
choisir de réintroduire ces
néonicotinoïdes donc le choix était fait
du modèle productiviste agricole de
celui de la production avec les produits
phytosanitaires qui parfois mettant
risque la santé des humains
un rapport de
l'université george washington de 2017
arabia noter le danger pour la santé
humaine de ces néonicotinoïdes on se
rappelle le gaucho par exemple en
amérique du sud qui a provoqué des
malformations génétiques des enfants qui
sont nés sans cerveau sans crâne des
malformations cardiaques et des troubles
neurologiques et bien en plus de la
disparition des abeilles
voilà ce qui a été choisi avec également
dans cette filière de la betterave
sucrière l'agro industrie qui produit
des aliments pas forcément très bon pour
la santé qui vont multiplier les cas de
diabète d'obésité mais l'économie
faisant la loi dans ce gouvernement est
dans ce moment on a choisi plutôt que de
mettre sur les rails une agriculture
paysanne où résonnait de continuer dans
l'agriculture intensive hérité des
années 80 et 90 et avec tout ça barbara
pompili et l'écologie ça donne quoi du
coup c'est compliqué pour barbara
pompili parce que c'est un symbole
hautement difficile pour elle elle avait
été la secrétaire d'état de françois
hollande à la biodiversité qui avait
lutté 1 pour que ces néonicotinoïdes
soit interdite et elle avait réussi et
la voilà ministre de la transition
écologique des modèles macron et elles
étaient avalés par le en même temps elle
a été dissoute dans la macro ni
puisqu'elle a été celle qui a interdit
de les néonicotinoïdes et en même temps
les ré autorise sur le marché donc elle
s'est cachée
c'était trop difficile pour elle sans
doute d'être face aux députés dans
l'assemblée nationale c'est julian
normandie qui a répondu aux questions
des députés elle a préféré partir par la
petite porte ne pas subir ce débat ce
débat qui va faire mal parce que
emmanuel macron a beaucoup de mal avec
l'écologie on se rappelle du départ
fracassant de nicolas hulot
on se rappelle de ce discours mec
planète great guen et puis des actes qui
derrière ne suivent pas l'écologie est
toujours à la traîne malgré les effets
d'annoncé
malgré les millions promis dans le plan
de relance on voit bien que cette loi
hautement symbolique voté à 313 députés
pour le retour de pesticides tueurs
d'abeilles fera mal et pourra coûter
cher peut-être en 2022 sachant que
l'écologie est au coeur de tous les
concitoyens même si bien sûr la filière
betterave doit être sanctuarisé puisque
nous sommes les numéros un mondiaux mais
choisir les betteraves face aux humains
c'est peut-être pas forcément un choix
politique très très malin merci beaucoup
alexis poulain c'est et notre rubrique
l'édito fois sixième semaine du procès
des attentats de janvier 2015 avec
depuis hier la parole donnée aux accusés
le point avec katia technique depuis la
cour d'assises spéciale de paris
depuis hier la cour tente de déterminer
si les 11 accusés étaient ou non au
courant des projets des terroristes
alors jusqu'ici deux accusés ont parlé
leur version convergent sur certains
points ils ont avoué avoir acheté des
objets qui ont été utilisés par amedi
coulibaly pour l'attentât de l'hyper
cacher mais il nie avoir su qu'il avait
des intentions terroristes
et puis chacun disculper l'autre lors du
côté des avocats de la défense
on s'agace que les faits reprochés soit
six mineurs c'est leur avis mais en
revanche certains sont scandalisés que
le responsable du trafic d'armes à les
fameuses humble qui vont servir à mehdi
coulibaly ne soit pas inculpé dans ce
dossier
il s'agit d'un indique un ancien indique
aussi un identitaire qui vivait dans le
nord à ce sujet je vous propose
d'écouter l'avocat de la défense jean
chevais le grand problème dans ce
dossier
c'est que dans le box il ya des
personnes qui n'ont rien à voir et que
dehors et aperçu des personnes qui ont
été même entendu comme témoin ou qui
vont l'être qui sont vraiment pour
quelque chose qui ont vraiment participé
et qui ne sont pas poursuivis
monsieur herman qui a reconnu avoir
vendu les armes à coulibaly il n'est pas
poursuivi
il a été poursuivi à lille en
correctionnelle parce qu'on a voulu
scinder les deux est caché caché quoi le
fait que monsieur herman et est un indic
de la police et l'indic prioritaire de
la gendarmerie et les gendarmes qui ont
été entendus en visioconférence qui
n'ont rien dit c'est manifestement un
camouflé et on a fait en sorte que
herman ne soit pas dans le box
parce qu'il aurait pu peut-être at-on
peur de révélations qu'il aurait pu
faire et puis il ya eu un incident cet
après midi l'ex compagne d'un des
prévenus christophe revel est venu à la
barre alors après avoir donné des infos
elle a accusé son ex-compagnon de
violences conjugales répétées et puis
également de menaces et d'agressions
juste avant le procès ce qui est
évidemment beaucoup plus grave
comment cela a été rendu possible et
bien cet accusé a été libérés puisque
les charges de terrorisme à son encontre
ont été abandonnées
donc ensuite il ya une suspension de
séance car elle a proféré des insultes
pour en tout cas aujourd'hui difficile
d'y voir clair entre terrorisme
banditisme est affaire de couple
restez avec nous sur rt france dans
quelques instants nous parlerons du
kyrgyzstan le premier ministre
démissionne à la suite de violents
heurts qui ont éclaté à l'annoncé des
résultats des élections les
l'islate iv puis direction les états
unis à donald trump ne présentent pas de
symptômes du comité 19 ce mardi à new
york 9 quartiers dont brooklyn et le
queens ont fermé leurs écoles pour
lutter contre la hausse des cas de
contamination au co vide a tout de suite
sur rt france
[Musique]
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu amadou gon
coulibaly était le candidat choisi à
l'unanimité dans des cadres du rhdp
malheureusement lui j'ai amadou gon pour
le valais est décédé pourquoi
aujourd'hui le président et candidat à
sa propre succession
estimant que le président ouattara est
celui qui a le leadership nécessaire
pour faire face au public se pose à nous
tant au niveau interne ou externe climat
particulier en ce moment en côte
d'ivoire était violence sous prétexte
d'une manifestation et d'expression de
droit démocratique
on incite à la haine on estime m est-ce
que sincèrement vous êtes certains que
le scrutin du 31 octobre s'est maintenu
à la date prévue
mais il n'y a pas de raison que ce
scrutin ne soit pas maintenu
ep
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et l'infante allant de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant et on refermait à vivre
mais dans une autre direction
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines la moitié de la
planète
jamais on a fait ça jamais fait d'une
décision à vraisemblable pour vous ça
dépend quelle valeur on attribuait la
mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie renoue
bien fait mais si on considère que
maintenant il va y avoir des
catastrophes humaines individuelles avec
cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral débats éthiques
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
je suis venu ici pour essayer de plonger
à la limite de mes capacités
l'énigme je n'aime pas le froid c'est un
défi en quelque sorte
essayez de plonger dans l'eau glacée oh
la vache
ce type qui a battu le record du monde
il a fait une autre plongée à 75 m je
dois plongé à 76 3 2 à départ
dans les banques où la diversité c'est
un autre point fort pas notre point
faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs un
cercle ohada et tout le monde discute et
finalement dumont discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois vous voyez des images
assez touchants de l'armée qui était
presque impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
c'est la cause d un politique et sont en
train de manipuler l'armée on sait très
bien pourquoi ils nous tirent dessus
sais pas s'ils savent que c'est leur fin
ils se préparent le seul langage qu'ils
connaissaient la violence il ne va pas
être violent mais on va rester
[Musique]
14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président tron va décider de rompre
l'accord et et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions au niveau international sur
1000 iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen orient
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sent du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend saft
est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autorités assez
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous le numéro i l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens ne
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
rodolphe gombergh vous avez découvert
que l'imagerie médicale qui était le
coeur de votre métier avait une
dimension artistique me suis aperçu que
c'était l'art qui faisait avancer la
science et la science qui faisait
avancer là l'image est belle mais mais
en général le mal qu'elle révèle
il est terrifiant au moment du coc vite
quand j'ai attrapé moi même
la balle a dit je me suis dit mais
pourquoi j'utilise pas ma technique de
droite et de virton life a pour mon
thorax propres et pour le virus j'ai pu
suivre son évolution
comment voyez ça s'aggravait ou au
contraire comment ça c'est mac mais
quand on a découvert le coït on sait qu
on sait comment ils et comment voir
quelle couleur il est qu'on a découvert
le mal les belges du mal
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris a tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi 6 octobre 2020 au kyrgyzstan le
premier ministre vient de démissionner
un peu plus tôt le kremlin se disait lui
préoccupé et appelait à une solution
dans la légalité
elle les élections législatives ont été
annulés ce matin par la commission
électorale au lendemain d'une nuit
d'émeutes soupçonnant des trucages lors
du scrutin
des milliers de manifestants ont envahi
le siège du gouvernement
ils ont aussi libéré de prison l'ex chef
de l'état almazek atambaïev
[Musique]
aux etats unis le locataire de la maison
blanche à regagner son domicile a testé
positif au co lead donald trump
l'assurent il se sent bien et il se dit
d'ailleurs impatient de débattre avec
joe biden le 15 octobre à new york
en revanche où le nombre des cas de
contamination est en forte hausse
les écoles de neuf quartiers sont fermés
à nouveau depuis aujourd'hui
[Musique]
paris/marseille éternelle source
d'inspiration après la cité phocéenne
elle c'est au tour de la capitale de
vouloir se doter de son propre conseil
scientifique qu'elle les deux villes
placées en zone d' alerte maximale face
aux commis de planche sur sa création
avec une même volonté donner de la
visibilité à la mairie dans sa gestion
du coc vider dans l'application des
restrictions
alors le conseil scientifique nationale
peut-il encore exister doit-on le
renouveler ou doit-il être déclinée
ville par ville
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
le premier ministre du kirghizstan
démissionne de ses fonctions le
parlement annonce qu'il a été remplacé
dans la foulée par un homme politique
libéré hier de prison par les
manifestants cette nuit la capitale du
pays a été le théâtre de violentes
émeutes soupçonnant des trucages lors du
scrutin
des milliers de personnes ont envahi le
siège du gouvernement
ce matin les élections législatives ont
été annulés par la commission électorale
à grasse d'aia et rania berrada scènes
de chaos devant le parlement kirghiz et
sa place à la touffe théâtre
d'affrontements violents dans la nuit de
lundi à mardi entre la police et les
manifestants
le bilan fait état de plus de 120
personnes blessées et d'au moins un mort
à l'origine de ces échauffourées les
élections législatives de ce dimanche à
l'issue du scrutin seules quatre des
seize partis en lice ont remporté la
totalité des 120 sièges des partis
proches du président soru beijing comme
des résultats controversés sur fond de
crainte d'irrégularités à l'origine de
la révolte il ya tant de choses qui ont
été brûlés et cassé tant de personnes
ont été blessées c'est une perte énorme
nous espérons que tout ira mieux quand
la tension baissera nous espérons que
tout ira mieux
prions pour qu'allah nous donne des
autorités juste de son côté le président
déplore la situation et tente de calmer
le jeu
watteau week end le gtno chers
compatriotes certaines forces politiques
ont tenté de s'emparer illégalement du
pouvoir la nuit dernière
elles ont utilisé les élections comme
prétexte et ont violemment perturbé
l'ordre public
privant les citoyens pacifiques de repos
j'ai proposé à la commission électorale
centrale de mener une enquête
approfondie sur les violations et si
nécessaire d'annuler les résultats du
vote
je demande aux dirigeants des partis
politiques de calmer leurs électeurs et
de les éloigner des lieux publics une
crise politique qui est temps alors que
du côté des observateurs l'eau et celle
organisée
pour la sécurité et la coopération en
europe semble satisfait du déroulement
des élections les élections législatives
du 4 octobre se sont déroulées dans le
cadre d'une législation améliorée il est
droits et libertés fondamentaux ont été
globalement respectée les allégations
crédibles d'achat de voix et à plus de
ressources administratives
tous deux interdits par la loi ont été
les plus préoccupantes pour notre équipe
d'observateurs non un avis qui n'est pas
partagé par les manifestants qui ont
libéré l'ex-chef d'état almazbek
atambaïev reconnu coupable de corruption
en juin est condamné à 11 ans de prison
on regarde l'aggravation de la situation
la commission électorale a décidé
finalement d'annuler le résultat des
élections législatives et pour en parler
nous sommes avec david de galles huser
chercheur associé à l'institut
montesquieu spécialiste du kyrgyzstan
david lee a usé remercie d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
le disait un nouveau premier ministre
nommé dans la confusion à au kirghizstan
après cette nuit de violences
post-électorales dans la capitale
bichkek
est-ce que les troubles peuvent
s'étendre au reste du pays
bonsoir oui oui bien sûr puisque le pays
s'articule en deux entités opposé que
sont le nord et le sud est
traditionnellement dans l'histoire le
nord s'oppose toujours au sud
donc quand le pouvoir est détenu par le
nord le sud leur éclat car le sud
détient le pouvoir le nord le réclame et
l'a donc le président actuel monsieur
jean baillet est issu du sud
donc il est solidement soutenu par sa
base qui sont dans les trois provinces
les régions méridionales dont jalalabad
est marqué et qui sont coincés aux
autres provinces du nord ou quatre
autres promesses du nord qui est le
soutiennent l ancien président alors
j'ouvre une parenthèse je précise que
l'ancien président ne reviendra pas au
pouvoir car il a déjà fait son temps il
reste populaire parmi les kirghiz mais
les kirghizes savent qu'il a été que
seront pouvoir était entachée
corruption donc ils préféreraient un de
ses premiers ministres qui a été
également libérer monsieur sa part
issakov qui al'avantage d'être jeune qui
n'a pas connu ou très peu l'époque
soviétique et qui pourrait représenter
une alternative à l'avenir alors du coup
pourquoi les les manifestants hier ont
choisi de libérer l'ancien président
almazek atambaïev un qui était
emprisonné depuis un an dans le bâtiment
officiel qu'est ce que ça révèle sa
rivale qu'il est toujours le porter le
porte étendard des kirghizes du nord et
également de la minorité ouzbèke au sud
mais surtout des kirghizes du nord et
qu'il a une assise solide bien entrer
dans cette partie là du pays dans les
oblasts dit si cool shoe dallas et
narines et et que les kirghizes de cette
partie la danse est un trio nahd et et
frondeuse par rapport aux nouvelles
autorités
surtout que au départ monsieur atambaïev
était dans le même parti que son
successeur qu'il avait lui-même proposé
avant que celui ci une fois élu lé les
cartes et finissent par les jeter en
prison
est ce que c'est c'est la première fois
que de telles manifestations se
déroulent pour demander l'annulation
d'une élection ou qui agissent temps est
ce qu'il ya eu des signes avant-coureurs
wii la wii le kirghizstan a quand même
connu deux révolutions auparavant qui se
sont déroulées au niveau pratique de la
même façon qu actuellement
mais ce qui est original cette fois ci
c'est que nous avons un soulèvement
après des élections législatives
en fait les kirghiz qui ont la
réputation d'être plus libre que le
chlore rose et en asie centrale
rick réclame du toujours et artifices
pour obtenir d'une autre manière ce
qu'il aurait refusée par des élections
entachées de fraudes
alors le chef de la mission de l'osce
cae a pourtant estimé que ces
législatives
c'était je cite plutôt bien déroulée
dans l'ensemble alors comment comprendre
cette observation que ce que ce soit au
niveau de l'organisation des bureaux de
vote en présentiel au niveau 6 du vente
électronique
il ya eu des moyens qui ont été
améliorés mais il faut quand même il
faut quand même savoir que au
kirghizstan l'achat de votes et est une
manière assez courante dans le pays où
souvent d une bonne partie de la
population parmi les classes n'est plus
la classe la plus pauvre peut être
sensiblement vulnérables et corruptible
par rapport par rapport à un vote
par exemple lors des dernières élections
on peut dire que simplement le fait
d'offrir un repas chaud le midi et le et
le soir s'il y avait un euro ou 30 euros
en plus ça suffit pour oran pour
corrompre un électeur et les hommes
politiques locaux semblent
malheureusement s'en servir en tout cas
ce système là était très présent encore
une fois lors des dernières élections
législatives alors un peu plus tôt le
kremlin s'est dit lui préoccupé en
appelant à une solution dans la légalité
quel rôle moscou peut jouer dans cette
crise qui se profile
moscou restera sur une opposition d'un
train parce que tout simplement
l'ensemble des partis kirghize n'est pas
n'est pas hostile à la russie 2
traditionnellement il ya une certaine
russe au feeling en cours au kirghizstan
je rappelle le russe est la deuxième
langue officielle du pays
il y à l'université slave et il y à
aussi
the russe au nord du pays près de
bichkek à quand
et donc les chaque force politique
cherchera à se mettre la pyrrhus dans sa
poche mais en fait la position de
monstres ou et plus particulièrement
donc nue du kremlin c'est celle
d'observer une neutralité et d'appeler à
l'apaisement des tensions
merci beaucoup d'avis de galles huser
pour votre éclairage je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur associé à l'institut
montesquieu et spécialiste du kyrgyzstan
et puis sachez que les combats
continuent dans le haut-karabagh entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan qui se
disputent ce territoire
de nouvelles frappes sur la capitale de
cette république autoproclamée ont été
observés le chef de la diplomatie turque
en déplacement à bakou appelle le monde
je cite à soutenir ceux qui sont dans
leur bon droit notamment l'azerbaïdjan
moscou dénonce une situation qui se
dégrade et appelle tout comme washington
et paris au cessez le feu dans une
interview le premier ministre arménien a
déclaré que son pays était prêt à des
concessions à condition que bakou en
face aussi à nikol pashinian qui s'est
également dit convaincu ne l'aide russe
en cas d' attaques sur son territoire
gilman à stepanakert les civils ont
bénéficié d'un court répit après 48
heures de bombardements la capitale de
la république du haut karabagh a profité
d'une nuit de calme les habitants ont pu
sortir ce mardi matin pour se
ravitailler et constater les dégâts
avant que les frappes ne reprennent de
plus belle en fin d'après-midi les
civils ont fait lourdement les frais du
conflit qui oppose arménie et
azerbaïdjan
loin des combats à l'arrière de la ligne
de contact la guerre reste omniprésente
à erevan le soutien au soldat s'affiche
sur grand écran dans les rues de la
capitale
faire vibrer la corde patriotique
arménienne de limiter ancien qui règne
entre les deux peuples
les volontaires continuent d'affluer
dans les services d'enrôlement ici des
dizaines d'algérie dans un bureau de
recrutement de bach ou là des arméniens
en partance pour le front les enfants
qui meurent là-bas certains viennent
d'ailleurs de très loin pour combattre
j'habite en france à strasbourg où il
est décédé venir et a beaucoup beaucoup
plus des gens qui sont là déjà de
strasbourg ou partie de france donc on
est là pour eux pour protéger notre
terre les enfants qui meurent là-bas on
my aller jusqu'au bout areva n'est bakou
se livre également une guerre de
l'information
les deux pays affirment chacun avoir
infligé plusieurs milliers de pertes
humaines à l'ennemi la communauté
internationale elle tarde à se mobiliser
le groupe de minsk créé lors de la
première guerre du haut karabagh il ya
près de 30 ans a instamment demandé un
cessez-le-feu
les représentants des pays coprésidents
du groupe de minsk de l'osce cee
condamne avec la plus grande fermeté les
escalades de violence inédite et
dangereuse survenus dans et en dehors de
la zone de conflit du haut karabagh les
attaques récentes qui aurait visé des
installations civiles et le caractère
disproportionné de telles attaques
constituent une menace inacceptable pour
la stabilité de la région
les ministres appellent une fois de plus
les parties au conflit à accepter un
cessez le feu immédiat et sans condition
d'autres membres de ce groupe comme
l'allemagne ou l'italie ont eux aussi
appelé à la fin des hostilités sans
prendre parti pour l'un des deux
belligérants
l'otan a fait de même tout comme l'iran
ou le canada seule voix dissonante celle
de la turquie depuis les premiers
affrontements ankara affiche un soutien
total à l'azerbaïdjan turcophone et
musulman et condamnent violemment le
voisin arménien le ministre des affaires
étrangères s'est même rendu ce mardi à
bakou où il a été reçu par le président
ilham aliev le mans l'azerbaïdjan
winston azerbaïdjanais et fitness a fait
des lettres l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
sur un pied d'égalité revient à
récompenser l'occupant cuse ankara de
déstabiliser la région en y envoyant
deux les mercenaires syrien
le monde doit soutenir ceux qui sont
dans leur bon droit nommément
l'azerbaïdjan une position turque
critiquée notamment par le président
syrien bachar el-assad qui accuse ankara
de déstabiliser la région en y envoyant
des mercenaires syrien adonis personnes
soutenaient les terroristes en syrie
tout comme en libye reste les bières
heroes nommé st gall il a été le
principal instigateur et initiateur du
récent conflit entre l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie dans le haut-karabagh in
nargorny karabakh week-end c'est faux on
peut être sûr qu'ils utilisent des
théories syrien et d'autres nationalités
dans le haut-karabagh hidalgo des cadres
dans la tente de solution diplomatique
concrètes
les affrontements se poursuivent donc
sans qu'une issue ne soient pour le
moment envisagée comme si de rien était
donald trump testé positif aux convives
19 est sortie de l'hôpital et a regagné
la maison blanche ils l'assurent je me
sens bien
peut-être un message adressé à ses
adversaires démocrates en pleine
campagne présidentielle
l'élection doit avoir lieu dans moins
d'un mois je vous le rappelle est donald
trump se dit impatiente débattre avec
joe biden ce sera le 15 octobre thé aux
combes
c'est un geste qui pourrait peser lourd
dans la campagne présidentielle
donald trump tout juste sorti de
l'hôpital militaire walter reed enlève
son masque comme un défi au corps
n'avait réussi à ses détracteurs
c'est donc hier soir que le président
américain est sorti après trois nuits
d'hospitalisation pour retrouver la
maison blanche
au terme d'une mise en scène savamment
orchestré problème le milliardaire de 74
ans pourrait toujours être contagieux
oui or mes proches et domestiques
nous restons tous prudemment optimiste
et sur nos gardes car administré ce
traitement un patient de manière si
précoce relève de l'expérimentation nous
regardons l'échéance de ce week end si
son état reste le même
mieux s'améliore d'ici lundi à ce moment
là nous serons tous soulagés
des déclarations qui n'ont pas dissuadé
donald trump de prendre les devants pour
rassurer ses électeurs sur son état de
santé
dans les vidéos publiées sur twitter il
appelle les américains à ne pas avoir
peur du coc vite 19
[Musique]
j'ai tellement appris sur le coronavirus
est une chose est sûre ne le laissez pas
vous contrôlez n'en ayez pas peur vous
alles et le vaincre nous avons le
meilleur matériel médical nous avons les
meilleurs médicaments tous développé
récemment et vous allez le battre j'y
suis allé et je me sentais pas très bien
il ya deux jours
j'aurais pu partir il ya deux jours il
ya deux jours je me sentais bien mieux
que je ne l'étais depuis longtemps j'ai
dit récemment mieux qu'il ya vingt ans
je savais qu'il y avait un danger mais
je devais le faire je suis resté devant
j'ai mené aucun dirigeant ne ferai ce
que j'ai fait distancée dans les
sondages par son adversaire démocrate le
locataire de la maison blanche ne
devrait pas retourner sur le terrain
dans l'immédiat une situation qui place
le 45e président américain en mauvaise
posture
joe biden lui continue sa campagne et
multiplie les piques à son encontre
la mersey tout d'abord permettez moi
également de dire que mes prières
continue d'aller vers le président la
première dame pour leur santé leur
sécurité alors que comme beaucoup de
familles américaines ils font face aux
convives 19
j'étais heureux de voir le président en
parler et enregistrer des vidéos ce
week-end maintenant qu'il est occupé à
tweeté des messages de campagne je lui
demanderais de faire ceci
écouter les scientifiques soutenait le
port du masque dans un pays qui subit
plus de deux cent dix mille morts dus
coronavirus et qui subit de plein fouet
les conséquences économiques de la crise
sanitaire
le temps presse pour les deux candidats
il ne reste plus que 28 jours avant
l'élection présidentielle
et pendant ce temps la ville de new york
var confiné certains quartiers depuis ce
matin les écoles de neuf quartiers de
brooklyn et du queens sont fermés le
gouverneur de l'état et le maire de la
ville sont en désaccord sur la question
de la fermeture des commerces non
essentiels à bill de blasio maire de new
york l'a pourtant assuré il fermement
tous dès demain mercredi à dans
certaines zones le taux de positivité de
cas est supérieur à 8% écouter le maire
de la ville
nous sommes à un moment crucial à new
york un moment crucial dans notre lutte
contre le coronavirus depuis sept mois
la ville mène une bataille et je tiens à
vous dire à tous que les new-yorkais ont
été héroïques dans cette bataille nous
devons lutter de façon systématique
contre le coronavirus maintenant nous
sommes face à un défi
nous constatons une augmentation des cas
dans certaines parties de notre ville et
nous devons aller de l'avant
nous devons tout mettre en oeuvre nous
devons être forts c'est pourquoi j'ai
proposé un plan pour remédier à la
situation
et oui cela implique des restrictions
sévères
nous ne voulons rien faire d'autre que
ce qui s'impose à nous nous voulons
devancer le problème pour qu'il reste
limitée et pour qu'on puisse y remédier
en quelques semaines et ne pas laisser
le virus se propageait et pour parler de
la situation aux etats-unis nous sommes
avec jérôme danard président du comité
français états unis bonsoir merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
la sortie de l'hôpital du président
donald trump une sortie finalement très
bien orchestré oui bah nous nous sommes
en plein dans les élections américaines
et donc j'irai quelque part on est
devant le show un spectacle vraiment
à l'image de ces élections américaines
tous les quatre ans nous avons des
candidats qui font tout pour attirer
l'attention des électeurs c'est un petit
peu le jeu ce qui est un petit peu
regrettable c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est
plutôt sur quelques veaux quelques
images et on parle très peu des
programmes et pourtant les programmes
entre programme démocrate et le
programme républicain
il y à de grandes différences et c'est
quand même ça qui est important puisque
les quatre prochaines années vont être
importantes autour les états unis et ça
serait bien qu'on puisse recentrer le
débat plus sur les idées que partagent
ces deux candidats parce que c'est vrai
qu effectivement on a vu le président
américain donald trump retiré son masque
joe biden lui s'est exprimé toujours
avec un masque
est ce que finalement c'est cette
question du masque qui risque d'être
finalement la question numéro à les
jours prochains dans la campagne
honnêtement pour connaître les états
unis et les américains je pense
qu'aujourd'hui au moment où on stars il
y à peu d'indécis dans l'électorat
américain
les américains pour moi ont fait leur
choix
maintenant il ya encore pratiquement 28
jours ou 27 jours avant la date de
finale de cette élection pour connaître
le nom du prochain président mais ce
sera à mon avis un sans surprise pour ce
que ça représente pour les américains
aujourd'hui on a tendance à trop
regarder ces élections américaines avec
le prisme français c'est une élection
qui est très compliqué on est déjà dans
un suffrage indirect avec deux partis
dominants
on ne parle que du parti démocrate et du
parti républicain mais pourtant il ya
aussi des partis minoritaires dans
l'élection présidentielle c'est à leur
importance et donc il
c'est vrai que c'est à la fois compliqué
mais passionnant c'est en tout cas c'est
beaucoup de ces sources d'interrogations
et peut-être aussi dans la compréhension
de la part des français donc c'est
important de resituer le débat alors on
a vu donald trump qui s'affiche en
pleine forme et il le dit je vais bien
finalement c'est sa stratégie pour ne
pas paraître fragilisé à moins d'un mois
de l'élection présidentielle et il peut
pas avoir notre discours
c'est le président des états unis et il
a été malade
aujourd'hui il doit avoir une parole
positive en disant vous voyez j'ai été
le touché j'ai été concernés maintenant
si vous aussi vous l'êtes
soyez forts et battez vous contre la
maladie
je pense que si jo byden ou un autre une
autre personne était à la place de
l'europe le discours on était quand même
globalement le même
alors est ce qu'on en sait d'ailleurs
davantage sur son état santé
est-ce qu'il est sorti en dépit de
l'avis des médecins
elle a écouté je peux pas répondre à
votre question je ne suis pas mais ça je
ne suis pas scientifique
est-ce que donald trump a outrepassé les
recommandations médicales que les
médecins ont pu lui proposer je ne peux
pas répondre je ne suis pas dans les
secrets de la maison blanche
en tout cas il est clair aujourd'hui
l'un trump eux rebondi sous un angle de
communication quand je vous disais il ya
quelques minutes
on assiste vraiment un show à
l'américaine on est dans la dernière
ligne droite de ces élections
présidentielles donc tout est permis il
me semble que nos jeunes aujourd'hui
tweets des photos avec son son chien
donc loyer et tout est fait pour attirer
l'attention alors dans le même temps
d'en parler des écoles de new york
1re ferme face à la hausse des cas
comment expliquer comprendre ce message
contradictoire
surtout quand donald trump finalement
appelle les américains à sortir
alors ça ça fait parti des spécificités
des états unis 1 nous avons en fin de
compte 50 et a un qui n ont un
fonctionnement
globalement tous autonome donc les
gouverneurs doivent gérer en fonction
des situations locales
là en l'occurrence il s'agit de la ville
de new york le maire a voulu s'engager
pour préserver la santé des new york et
c'est tout à son honneur
après il faut juste intégré que derrière
il ya quand même 10 arrière pensées
politiques
1 le maire de new york bill de blasio
avait des ambitions nationales
un gain de temps au sein du parti
démocrate
1 pour se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle
donc peut-être que c'est aussi pour
avoir un
on va dire de vente scène médiatique par
rapport à ce qui n'a pas pu obtenir dans
les primaires démocrates et à avoir une
existence plus politique pour sa
carrière dans les mois voire les années
à venir
merci beaucoup je dis romdhane art pour
votre éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes président du
comité france etats-unis est resté avec
nous sur rt france dans quelques
instants nous parlons de la lutte face
au co vide
après la cité phocéenne c'est au tour de
la capitale de vouloir se doter de son
propre conseil scientifique alors le
conseil scientifique nationale peut-il
encore exister doit-on le renouveler ou
doit-il être déclinée ville par ville
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face à
tout de suite sur rt france
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que si ben voilà c'est fini pour
moi est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du majeur mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président tram va décider de rompre
l'accord et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions au niveau international sur
1000 iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen orient
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans ses
cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'ils
avaient une équipe de 25 usiniers autour
pour nous pour nos fournisseurs pour nos
équipes c'était essentiel d'ouvrir le
plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mid de la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le monde d'avant il
était formidable et qu'on a envie de le
retrouver je pensais que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et ça m'a rendu
plus intolérant alors par mois elle
s'était passionnée vous posez justement
délirer autour d'un dessert que j'ai
appelé la pêche la patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tonique que le monde d'avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur arte france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française
et on commence avec la situation
sanitaire en france et les derniers
chiffres de santé publique france
l'agent s'annonce plus deux à dix mille
400 nouvelles contaminations aux comics
19 en 24 heures soixante cinq personnes
sont décédées à l'hôpital et 168
patients ont été admis en réanimation au
total 7377 malades sont actuellement
hospitalisées pour le coc vide 19 et
dans ce contexte la ville de marseille
elle a adopté une proposition inédite ce
lundi lors du conseil municipal
elle va constituer son propre conseil
scientifique
la mère michel rubio la devrait être la
présidente et le professeur didier
raoult et pourrait être un membre
une proposition et des informations de
samia ghali la deuxième adjointe à la
mairie
selon elle marseille se porterait mieux
à ne pas être dirigé par des
scientifiques parisien à qui ne
connaissent pas les problèmes de la
ville paris elle aussi planche sur la
création d'un comité spécialement pour
la capitale une des instances locales
donc pour s'opposer à leurs pendants
nationale
le rôle du conseil scientifique au vide
19 en images tout de suite avec elvire
le d'horreur le 10 mars 2020 mise en
place par le gouvernement pour lui
permettre d'avoir les dernières
informations scientifiques sur
l'épidémie
le 3 avril 2020 officialisation par
décret sous le nom de comité de
scientifiques
le conseil scientifique sera dissous le
jour où l'état d'urgence prendra fin si
en france il était prévu que son
existence prennent fin le 10 juillet la
reprise de l'épidémie observé en juin
force le comité a continué sa mission
auprès du gouvernement
un président jean françois delfraissy
immunologue de formation il a été nommé
par décret du président de la république
quatorze membres début puis 13 après le
départ du professeur raoul
parmi eux anthropologue épidémiologistes
virologues infectiologues médecin il
donne son avis sur la situation
sanitaire mais il a aussi un pouvoir
décisionnaire leurs connaissances
scientifiques leur permettent de prendre
les mesures adéquates et de fixer la
durée de leurs applications
[Musique]
ces mesures ne lit pas le gouvernement
et sont vendues en toute indépendance au
sol vu de l'intérêt général du pays
stipule le règlement intérieur de ce
conseil
dernièrement il a décidé que la période
d'isolement des cas positifs passé de 14
jours à 7 jours les membres ne doivent
percevoir aucune rémunération avantages
dans le cadre de cette fonction alors
que chaque mairie souhaite avant tout
avoir de la visibilité dans sa gestion
du coc vider dans l'application des
restrictions le conseil scientifique
national est il dépassé doit-on le
renouveler ou doit-il être décliné dans
chaque ville on en parle tout de suite
dans notre face à face et nous sommes
avec alain houpert radiologue sénateurs
les républicains de la côte d'or avec
mais également par téléphone marguerite
médecins généralistes député la
république en marge de l'aisne messieurs
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors marseille a on le
disait elle va donc se doter de son
propre conseil scientifique avec comme
intention d'être au plus proche de la
situation quotidien et permettent que
des personnalités marseillaise puisse
disputer et faire des propositions
plutôt que de laisser faire l'état alors
alain houpert est ce que c'est une bonne
idée j'ai observé avec attention la
proposition de samia ghali qui était une
de mes collègues puisqu'elle était
sénatrice
je comprends sa démarche ce que le
professeur out qui est un éminent
scientifique a été traîné dans la boue
et conseil scientifique nationale dans
lequel il a finalement déficit décidé
d'abandonner son siège qui était composé
de sept membres qui
des conflits d'intérêts avec des
laboratoires et je comprends que c'était
du sénégal et de marseille sont sa fille
sa ville discriminés par rapport à
décision parisienne et un comité
scientifique parisien particulièrement
chez jp morgan
est ce que vous vous partagez ce constat
qu'on s'identifie qu un particulièrement
suspect pour alain houpert
est ce que vous comprenez ce choix de
samia ghali finalement est bien de
fonder son propre conseil scientifique
écoutez j'ai auprès des e renaud
muselier saint lô
quand cette décision et je pense que le
conseil scientifique n'a pas failli dans
ses missions d'ailleurs début juillet et
l'avait annoncé il est d'ailleurs une
demande expresse express de notre pays
tina quant à prolonger sa mission
il avait déjà non deuxième vague en
septembre octobre il avait signalé
justement là que le processus se
déroulerait sur les au moins 20 grandes
métropoles françaises et pour une
population plus jeune donc il a loin il
est loin d'être failli dans sa mission
et je pense qu'il est tout à fait
légitime dans sa mission technique quant
à éclairer les décisions politiques
alors ouvert qu'est ce que vous répondez
est-ce que ce conseil scientifique à
quel niveau vous vous l'avez vu faillir
je n'ai jamais fait mystère de ma
proximité de pensée avec didier rahout
la médecine est une science qui est
guidé par un doute permanent et le
conseil scientifique se fait un instant
t parce que l'état des connaissances
permettent d'aboutir un qu'on sait qu un
consensus
jusqu'à ce que de nouvelles découvertes
le perdre le remette en question
donc j'ai vu lors de ce conseil
scientifique opposé des molécules et des
protocoles ajouter des comités au comité
et voir que l'exécutif décide d'une
médecine officielle la parole de
monsieur de la tse la parole de la
pensée unique
pour moi il faut laisser les médecins
prescrire
je suis partisan d'une médecine
participative active où le patient est
acteur de sa guérison
on n'a pas besoin de match un
administratif de plus mais d'un exécutif
qui fasse confiance au médecin confiance
aux médecins et de médecin qui accepte
la responsabilité d'aider guidant et des
soignants face à leurs patients la
médecine c'est une relation entre le
patient et le souhait marque de là
qu'est ce que vous répondez à laon père
quand il vous dit vous êtes le porte
parole finalement d'une médecine
officielle d'une pensée unique et qu'il
faut laisser le médecin prescrire quelle
est votre réponse
on est droit d'être d'être dans une
pensée unique que le patient soit acteur
de santé et y aller bien évidemment il
faut tendre sur le fait que le patient
soit acteur de santé mais enfin quand on
voit la composition du comité
scientifique nous avons quand même des
gens de haute compétence et qui ont
justement tout le
le discernement quant à donner des
éléments pour que le politique décide
pour moi la problématique si vous voulez
audace et c'est toute la problématique
de l'effondrement de la confiance
vis-à-vis des scientifiques pas
seulement entre les politiques publiques
mais aussi des politiciens et du public
avec la science d'autant plus que lorsqu
on recommande effectivement que les
conseillers recommande eu de nouvelles
restrictions aux libertés mais dans un
pour le bien commun et donc si vous
voulez il faut pas avoir peur en fait tu
utilises d'accord c'est ce que
d'ailleurs fait à noter deux revenants
dans un celi et on est certainement plus
dans le niveau du débat plutôt que du
consensus
après vous savez les l'information le
comité scientifique il est pas seul il
interagit avec la haute autorité de
santé avec santé publique france et
l'ensemble des comités scientifiques
mondiaux donc arrêtons de faire un
procès politique à un comité
scientifique donne qui fait son travail
du contenu technique qui oriente
discernement les déficients des
politiques alors sur cette volonté de
créer un vrai conseil scientifique au
niveau local l'objet de notre débat je
vous propose d'écouter ce que disait
hier sur notre antenne fabrice di vizio
il est avocat de soignants ont
l'écoutons réagi ensuite il n'y a pas de
réalité des territoires
il ya une réalité qu'à deux réalités
nationales on a un virus qui circulent
soit territoire national alors avec plus
ou moins d'incidents selon les régions
mais je veux dire alors demain matin
est-ce qu'il faut que marseille se dote
de son propre conseil de défense et de
son propre conseil de sécurité à quand
une police municipale armée est
effectivement un tribunal et une loi
marseillaise vous voulez quoi rétablir
les coutumes le coutumier du mauvais
this suis là parce qu'on en est là un
moment donné c'est à dire
qu'effectivement concrètement il m'avait
semblé que l'état unitaire et que
l'unité de l'état qu'un progrès dans
l'histoire droit là tout à coup on est
en train d'effectivement rester me
restaurer des espèces de coutume locale
avec des conseils locaux
mais tout ça va engendrer une confusion
supplémentaire elle marque de l'ade
médecins généralistes débuté la
république en marche
laine vous rejoignez ce constat de
fabrice di vizio aujourd'hui pas de
réalité de territoire mais une réalité
nationale
alors qui est une réalité nationale dans
le cadre du de décisions qui touchent
toute la population l'hexagone de même
que les outre-mer est vide a évidemment
mais qu'il fallait aussi concerté qui
est des dispositifs par exemple de
liaison pour des formes de participation
délibération citoyenne pour pourquoi pas
mais de là à douter effectivement chaque
petit petites tentes adieux du d'un
comité scientifique très sincèrement
alors que justement le comité
scientifique a fait preuve de son
efficacité
ça n'a pas de sens et en plus s'il
voulait ça ça entraîne le virus si vous
voulez circulent
nous n'avons actuellement pas d'outil
préventives comme le vaccin on n'a pas
un taux d'immunité collectif suffisant
on est à peine allant de 5% et de ce
fait nous nous sommes pris par le temps
et la réactivité elle passe par des
décisions effectivement plus pire
pyramidale si on peut dire mais qui
doivent se tenir sur les réalités de
terrain dans la mesure où des vieux
schémas six volumes ne sont pas
statiques sur les schémas concernant la
limitation des propagations il faut bien
dire que dans les métropoles
effectivement il ya une concentration de
population bien plus élevé est ce qui
explique que cette capitulation du virus
est plus aux îles protéger les plus
fragiles ils sont plus de 22 millions
donc toutes les mesures qui ont été
faites en faveur des ehpad
notamment il ya une saisine du cce pour
l'idée la souffrance qu'ils connaissent
et il est avec nous comment dirais-je
avec la préconisation de geste barrière
la sphère du bon sens mais on est dans
un processus dynamique qui nécessite une
réactivité une adaptation en fonction
des territoires
c'est ce que préconise dans les options
que le cas donné le comité scientifique
notamment des options
qu'ils reposent si vous voulez sur les
attitudes mesure différencier une route
sur dix est si on me dit aux modérés
voire de mesures fortes en fonction du
taux d'incidence
c'est ce qu'a proposé le conseil
scientifique de façon très pragmatique
et à laon père justement ça ça
fonctionne on passe selon vous cela
proposer le conseil scientifique
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec
monsieur le conseil scientifique a
montré son insuffisance et de faire des
conseils scientifiques locaux
il ya trois dangers le premier comme l'a
dit renaud muselier ces deux d'un machin
administrative de puces au deuil mais
qui va au delà de la formule du général
et à force d'éclairer dans tous les sens
on va finir par éblouir et pu lire çà ne
verra plus rien deuxième danger celui du
clientélisme avec le risque plus grande
une proximité avec les élus et les
laboratoires installés en région et qui
ce qui risque de multiplier la suspicion
est le troisième danger c'est de santé
les cartes la santé
c'est un restaurant cpo menu et c'est
pas du tout à la carte
alors regardez ce que pense le
professeur arnaud fontanet il est membre
du conseil scientifique kovy 19 et pour
lui il y as peut-être aussi un problème
de personnes regardent et nous avons
déjà travaillé pendant quatre cinq mois
dans des conditions éprouvantes
je suis convaincu qu'il faille de
nouvelles personnes dont le conseil
scientifique parce qu'il faut que des
idées nouvelles arrivent
marguerite c'est une urgence il faut
aujourd'hui des nouvelles personnes dans
ce conseil scientifique vous rejoignez
ses propos du professeur fontanet p
crédit de quoi qu'il en soit l'idée de
nouveau de nouvelles personnes c'est à
s'impliquer aussi de nouvelles
compétences
après vous savez vous le savez bien nous
sommes dans un air d'une médecine
prédictive l'épidémiologie et est une
science qui nécessite d'avoir aussi des
compétences dans le domaine du numérique
donc le le conseil scientifique
d'ailleurs s'est renforcé à ce niveau
puisque vous n'avez pas que des médecins
vous avez des sociologues des
spécialistes concernant le
le numérique dans le sang semblent des
personnes qui le composent donc ils
n'ont pas attendu si vous voulez de de
renforcer au delà au delà de dd des
médecins il ya aussi mari à l'aide grard
qui est dans le milieu associatif
emmerinois angles dans les nouvelles
technologies
voyez dans donc au bout daniel
benamouzig qui est sociologue
donc on a on a une multiplicité de 2,2
de vision de de richesse au niveau des
compétences alors à la ouvert on vous
voyez à lever les yeux au ciel quand
marc delas de prononcer les multiples
qu'on fait quand compétences pardon
qu'il ya au sein de ce conseil
scientifique
quel est votre avis à ce sujet
compétences vous avais dit le mot
compétences je pense que pour un con
ciel scientifique consacrée à une
épidémie de cette ampleur il faut des
vrais compétences et ce sont des
scientifiques des médecins et le conseil
scientifique a vraiment montré son
incompétence par ses conflits d'intérêts
sa suggestion aussi à la halle aux mails
ski qui a fait un pas en avant et deux
pas en arrière
il est vrai qu'on ne sait rien face à
cette épidémie on sait pas grand chose
mais il ya des endroits où ça marche
les faits sont têtus et on est face à un
gouvernement tqt tube c'est ça le
problème qui ne reculait devant rien
souvenez-vous du décret d'olivier vire
en interdisant la chloroquine ce décret
être email
maintenant on peut prescrire la
chloroquine mais surtout pas associé à
l'azithromycine et on peut
prescrira l'azithromycine surtout pas
associé à la couleur au pied donc on
voit bien on voit bien que ce
gouvernement veut qu'on joue cacher son
incompétence et sa responsabilité
marc de l'ade ce sera pour vous le mot
de la fin
alors est-ce qu'on renouvelle ou en
décline le conseil scientifique
bah écoute et on leur nouvelle je crois
qu'il faut pas avoir peur du désaccord
il faut savoir aussi que la connaissance
du vélo y sont depuis plusieurs mois
nous a permis de mieux prendre en charge
les malades en réanimation
ce qui fait que en associant notamment
les corticoïdes examina zones
intérieures mieux l'oxygène des
thérapies nous sommes beaucoup plus à
même de sauver des vies donc quand je
veux pas revenir sur le débat de
l'exacte leur quine qui n'a jamais même
pas montrer réellement sa preuve
et ça c'est un faux procès avec une
politique à une politisation outrancière
que je t'aime nancy rennes et dans un
contexte de pur délire
voyons restons sérieux en tout cas un
grand merci à tous les deux d'avoir joué
le jeu du n'est pas alain houpert je
rappelle que vous êtes radiologue
sénateurs les républicains de la côte
d'or marc delanne médecins généralistes
député la république en marge de l'aisne
merci à tous les deux et une déclaration
commune pour dénoncer des sanctions
jugées injustes dans un contexte de
crise sanitaire moscou pékin pyongyang
ou encore téhéran appel à la levée des
sanctions de washington et d'autres
capitales occidentales est des punitions
qui selon les signataires viole les
droits humains dans la lutte contre la
pandémie walid bennani crise sanitaire
crise économique
chaque nation tentent de vivre survivre
à une pandémie dévastatrice
hier lors d'une réunion de la troisième
commission de l'assemblée générale de
l'onu spécialisée dans les droits
humains
l'ambassadeur de chine auprès des
nations unies s'est mué en porte parole
d'une fronde presque scientifique
nous saisissons cette occasion pour
appeler à la levée complète et immédiate
des mesures coercitives unilatérales
afin de permettre une réponse aux
qu'ovide 19 complète et efficace de tous
les membres de la communauté
internationale 26 signataires dans la
biélorussie la corée du nord neuf pays
africains ou encore les deux géants
chinois et russes 26 nations qui
s'adresse notamment aux états unis et
aux pays occidentaux
nous continuons d'assister à
l'application de mesures coercitives
unilatérales contraires aux buts et
principes de la charte des nations unies
et du droit international au
multilatéralisme et aux normes
fondamentales des relations
internationales un véritable pamphlet à
l'égard des grandes nations du monde
pour exemple les états unis ont
unilatéralement proclamé le 20 septembre
dernier le retour aux sanctions des
nations unies contre l'iran si les gens
veulent me dire la source des lacunes et
des problèmes du pays
l'adresse est à la maison blanche à
washington ses fidèles
washington et ses dernières trois années
ils ont empêché à travers des opérations
terroristes l'achat des médicaments et
de nourriture
en imposant des sanctions injustes
illégales et inhumaines qui ont coûté au
pays au moins 150 milliards de dollars
le maroc radio et le guéry staline à une
pression liée au nucléaire un dossier
sensible
il ya un an paris londres ou encore
berlin était également favorable au
maintien de sanctions adoptées en 2017
par l'onu à l'encontre de la corée du
nord pour lui faire arrêter ses
programmes d'armement nucléaire
la réélection controversée du président
biélorusse une nouvelle loi sécuritaire
en kong en posées par la chine ou encore
le gouvernement vénézuélien de nicolás
maduro des dossiers chauds certes mais
aujourd'hui pékin et 25 entre nations
appelle plus que jamais à une solidarité
face à un virus des plus mortels
la pandémie de covin 19 continue
d'affecter gravement toutes les nations
en particulier des pays en développement
la réponse au coït 19 et le
rétablissement des pays nécessite une
solidarité mondiale et une coopération
internationale
des déclarations qui rejoignent celles
de la haute commissaire des nations
unies aux droits de l'homme
michelle bachelet favorable dès mars à
l'assouplissement aux suspensions de ces
sanctions
pour éviter l'effondrement de systèmes
de santé déjà fragile ces dernières
semaines les états unis et leurs alliés
européens ont affirmé que les sanctions
imposées ne concerne pas le domaine
humanitaire
est ce la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve dans un peu moins de dix
minutes pour un point complet sur
l'actualité est resté avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]
tout